[Music]
this is Star Talk special edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist Chuck how you doing man
hey Neil what's happening all right
Chuck professional comedian and actor
and of course uh Gary O'Reilly Gary
former Soccer Pro so what what have you
what have you and your producers fellow
producers cooked up for this episode
it's all starts tragically but not too
tragically I hope but with a family
illness and I'll guess put their media
life on hold and went in search of
answers so here we have curiosity
years of investigative research led to
the New York Times instant bestseller
genius Foods
that was followed by genius life and
third book genius kitchen let's meet our
guest a podcaster a filmmaker author and
wellness journalist plus a tedx speaker
and probably in a minute we'll find out
much much more Neil Max lugavier Max
welcome to StarTalk hi Neil big fan
thank you so much for having me good
should I do I trust Gary's pronunciation
of your last name
yeah he did it he did a fantastic job
and that's how I've been hearing it
actually I was in London for uh a week a
week just uh just up until two weeks ago
and it was really fun being there for
the first time and shockingly I
discovered this is very new research
that um Alzheimer's disease and dementia
is now the UK's number one cause of
death if I was there talking about the
role of nutrition brain health and it
was um I mean it was my first time
getting to explore London it was a blast
you have a good time
I did have a good time you know as a
great City yeah fantastic city
um great food which uh I wasn't quite
expecting not known for that yeah no for
that it didn't used to be
there's no there's no restaurants in
town they say British Cuisine those two
words yeah that means mashed potatoes
sausages Fish and Chips baked beans and
then you're done you're done you kind of
you're kind of done there so Max uh this
this portfolio of expertise
um uh did you do you come to it through
your roots as a as a health journalist a
wellness journalist
yeah so I um I always like to be very
clear up front I'm not a medical doctor
I didn't go through the the traditional
academic channels I started my career as
a generalist journalist I worked for Al
Gore for six years for a TV network
called current TV and then my mother got
sick at a very young age and I became
obsessed with trying to understand
everything I possibly could about the
role of diet and lifestyle in brain
health as well as mental health and
um I've published a lot of literature as
you you know have mentioned
um three books on the topic exploring
the intersection between our diets and
our lifestyles and disease outcomes
brain health
etc etc but um which obviously are
geared towards towards lay audiences but
I've also had the privilege of getting
to co-author academic work so I got to
co-author a chapter in a textbook
um geared to clinicians in a handbook on
the neuropsychology of aging and
dementia on the clinical practice of uh
of dementia prevention and then I also
have got to work for Medscape which is
the largest publication reaching doctors
all around the world so yeah Medical
Health and Science journalist is sort of
my my professional title but um but I
create content I have a podcast I you
know go on television to again to lay
audiences and
um and I'm largely an auto didac but
despite that I've I've gotten to do
really incredible stuff I lecture around
the world on this topic and it's uh it's
fun but the reason why I got into it is
because again at a young age my mom got
sick and so that is my my why and she
passed away four years ago but trying to
understand why
she developed this rare the rare form of
dementia that she had has become really
my life's purpose
and so and you so you have so you like
the word genius because it's in three of
your books
the podcast and your podcast a genius
life so no one doesn't want to be a
genius so that's quite the magnetic draw
for potential audiences out there so so
let's start off by asking I I guess you
would say there's some foods that are
good for the brain and some foods that
are not they're going to take the very
naive view the foods I like from my
brain are the ones that taste good
because then I'm happy and my brain and
my mind if I'm happy I'm happy right so
so I have a I have french fries or kale
when I'm done eating the french fries I
am happier than when I eat the bowl of
kale so but I'm betting that's not the
kind of thing you're talking about
yeah well first off I do want to address
the the genius aspect of the you know
titling nomenclature that I've used and
and part of the reason why I chose that
is not to say that I'm a genius and that
I have some profound secret insights to
offer
um although I do like to think that at
times it's really that I want to create
the ultimate sort of nutritional care
manual for the brain the Ulta ultimate
dementia prevention road map but I
realized that young people wouldn't be
interested in such a topic and one of
the most startling insights that I
discovered when I when I set foot on
this journey was that dementia often
begins in the brain decades before the
first symptom 30 to 40 years prior to
the first symptom so in my estimation
this is very much like a millennial
topic that we needed to be talking about
and so I started looking at food I'm
I've always been a big nutrition junkie
and so with regard to your uh your
dilemma your French fries and and kale
dilemma
yeah french fries are generally speaking
well there's a Continuum like food isn't
necessarily food right like fat isn't
fat protein isn't protein and french
fries can be made really healthily if
you're using an air fryer or if you're
using if you're using a type of fat that
is chemical if you're using spinach yeah
if you're using spinach to what to fryer
to make your French fries yeah
there you go I'm talking about authentic
original McDonald's lard fried potato
lard fried french fries well yeah I mean
unfortunately McDonald's today they're
not frying their french fries in lard I
would be somewhat I think more amenable
to french fries fried and lard because
instead what they use are these Ultra
processed refined bleached and
deodorized Seed oils which oftentimes
are sitting in the fryers for days right
now these oils if quote unquote fresh
they're never actually fresh because
they're so highly refined and processed
but just for all intents and purposes if
they were you know changing these oil
these fryers regular early we'd have
less of an issue but unfortunately when
these oils are held at temperature they
generate really
um nasty compounds like certain
aldehydes which we know are potentially
mutagenic can damage the energy
producing mitochondria in our cells
and they create trans fats which we know
there's no safe level of trans fat
consumption and so I think that's you
know combined with the fact that french
fries tend to be hyper palatable they
imbue this characteristic that food
scientists refer to as hyperpalatability
they're almost impossible to moderate
our consumption of those Foods I think
that's really where the the problem
tends to lie but you can make french
fries at home using you know Tallow or
you know if you wanted lard I mean my
personal favorite and I think probably
the healthiest choice would be an
unsaturated fat like you know avocado
oil or extra virgin olive oil extra
virgin french fries are amazing my 10
year old makes them in the air frying
toaster oven that we have and I and by
the way the same where you can make the
french fries all you got to do is slice
those same potatoes very thinly and in
the exact same way you can make your own
fresh potato chips baby I will never buy
another bag of potato chips again a lot
you're lying
um max what are the genius Foods because
there's got to be like a police lineup
of the good guys and the bad guys so
let's hit the good guys shall we yeah
absolutely so when I started looking to
the literature I really wanted to rather
than like come out of the gate with the
foods that people ought to be avoiding
which can be really overwhelming and I
think kind of it's a that's a pretty
common Trope in the in the diet industry
you know the diet culture yeah it tends
to really love to vilify Foods the
genius foods are the foods that you
should actually adopt and embrace and
consume more of and so these are foods
like avocados which
um you know living in California I'm
kind of preaching to the choir but
generally avocados are an incredible
brain food because of their abundance of
fat protect using antioxidants like
vitamin E and carotenoids like lutein
and zeaxanthin which we've known for
decades can help protect the eyes
against age-related macular degeneration
we now know that these same compounds
actually accumulate in the brain where
they protect the brain from oxidative
stress they boost something called
neural efficiency meaning suggesting
that your brain might actually if we
consume more of these work less hard to
achieve the same tasks
they also can boost visual processing
speed according to research out of the
University of Georgia so avocados are
tremendous I'm also a huge fan of eggs
you know eggs no pun intended have taken
a beating over the past couple of times
he's here all week he's here all week
I'm here all week yeah but but the egg
yolk is literally uh one of Nature's
multivitamins it contains a little bit
of everything required to grow and
sustain a healthy brain I mean it's no
wonder that egg yolks contain
cholesterol which has been the vilified
nutrients in question for you know since
probably the 1970s the brain is made of
cholesterol 70 25 of the of total body
cholesterol is housed in the brain which
accounts only for two to three percent
of your body's mass now I'm not saying
you need to consume cholesterol for
brain health your brain produces all the
cholesterol that it needs in a process
called de novo cholesterol synthesis but
all that is to say it's no wonder that
egg yolks contain an abundance of
cholesterol because it's there to help
grow a brain so eggs are amazing they
contain choline which we see in older
men there was a study that found that
even if you were genetically at risk for
developing Alzheimer's disease the
highest level of choline intake was
associated with a 30 risk reduction for
the development of Alzheimer's disease
so eggs are tremendous
so if you're rich will will caviar work
as a substitute
yeah I like this I actually like this
question because caviar provides a form
of decosa hexaneoic acid AKA DHA fat
which is
there you go that was a getting my
learning how to pronounce that
accurately
umoic acidoic acid you know it yeah all
right you know it yeah it's so
um so yeah DHA fat it's one of the most
important structural building blocks of
the brain we we typically don't consume
uh enough of it in the context of the
standard American diet and uh fish eggs
like caviar and and um salmon Roe ikora
in Japanese restaurants is actually a
wonderful source of DHA fat and in
particular it's a source of DHA fat in
what's called a phospholipid format
which is like Plug and Play to the brain
it just gets sucked up by the brain and
integrated into cellular membrane say
fat in uh certain kinds of cold water
fish too is that the case yeah exactly
so wild salmon sardines mackerel great
source of DHA fat right now a lot you
know people will look to pla especially
today there's this like this push
towards plant-based diets which I think
is you know if you if you choose to be
on a plant-based diet by all means do it
I just you know Aspire so that I I hope
that people have the full breadth of
information before making a choice like
that a lot of people will look to like
flaxseed oil or chia seeds for their
Omega-3s but men in particular are very
poor at converting plant-based forms of
Omega-3s to their usable form in the
body which is you know one one of those
uh important omega-3 fatty acids it's
DHA fat so I prefer to get it from fish
Chuck I don't blame you oh wait just
that back up for a sec so
you make a point but I don't want to I
don't want you to just skip by it you
recognize that just because you eat a
molecule doesn't mean that molecule
retains its molecular form and then gets
used by the body in that state there's a
lot of molecules we eat that we
decompose and reassemble according to
the body's needs so just because you
know a chemical is used in the brain why
should consuming that chemical chemical
automatically mean it lands in your
brain to do just what you think it
should
yeah you're absolutely right I mean we
should we shouldn't assume that I mean
so DHA fat you can get it in there are
multiple forms that DHA fat uh appears
in the diet so typically you we ingest
it in its triglyceride form that's how
it's found in fish but then krill oil
um salmon Roe for example have it in the
phospholipid form which is thought to be
more bioavailable to the brain
and a lot of people on plant-based diets
will look to alpha linolenic acid or ala
which is a plant-based form of Omega-3s
assuming that we all transform this
plant-based compound to its usable form
in the body but that's actually
um not correct thinking because we all
are different and we all vary in our
capacity to transform that compound to
its usable form in the body there are
enzymes like the Delta 5 desaturates
enzyme and there are minerals that are
rate limiting in this process so you
know in the nutrient deficient standard
American diet I mean it's just it's
leaving a lot to chance and where our
brains are concerned that's not
something that you want to leave to
chance you want to make sure that you
are I mean essentially what I call the
set it and forget it method you want to
and make sure that you're ingesting
pre-formed DHA fat pre-formed EPA fat
people of different genetic backgrounds
people with different genders for
example like men are worse at this than
women women are about 10 times more
effective at converting ala to DHA which
is thought to be an adaptation to
support child
um rearing
and so yeah you're absolutely right we
can't just like
you know we don't want we want to take
the guesswork out of this nutrition is
far too important
so what evidence do you have that your
mother's condition which launched you on
this quest to associate food and
nutrition with brain health what
evidence do you have that had she eaten
differently for example that her
condition might have been delayed
or
ameliorated entirely
like is there because you can't just
blow people up and do brain experiments
on them right this is this is not not
yet but
yes come on now not yet no well we're we
we are starting to see first of all that
rates of Alzheimer's and Dementia are
increasing across across different age
groups so this is not just the oldest
old this is not just a function of the
fact that we are living longer in fact
we're actually dying longer we're
spending more of our years with
disabilities saddled by by chronic
disease
but then you see that the standard well
first of all actually so there's there's
a lot of ways to approach this and I
think it's a fantastic question
so one of the most well-defined
Alzheimer's risk genes is called the
apoe4 allele and we carry about one in
four of us carry it here in the United
States right and in the United States
that carrying whether you carry one or
two copies increases your risk anywhere
between 2 and 14 fold it was recently
revealed that Chris Hemsworth for
example on on a show that he did carries
two copies right so that's a dramatic
you know risk increase but risk is
correlation and these studies to
ascertain the degree of risk increase
are all performed here in the United
States if you were to look to another
part of the world where say ibadan
Nigeria where they've done this they see
the same gene frequency so again roughly
one in four people carry the gene there
but there it has little to no
association with Alzheimer's disease so
essentially that Gene increases your
risk in the context of the standard
American diet right but if you were to
Simply Move Yourself to another part of
the world a part of the world say where
the food supply is less industrialized
where you know there tends to be tighter
social connections where people tend to
be more active less sedentary less
exposed to environmental pollutants Etc
you might see that risk abolished so
genes are not suggested what you're
saying is risk doesn't necessitate
outcome exactly the potential for the
outcome is to be there but what we know
environmentally is as we make
environmental associations associated
with that risk we see a decline in other
areas where they don't have the hazards
of diet that we experience here in the
United States yeah exactly is the
concept known as epigenetics so you
might you know we all you might carry uh
think of your genes like the keys on a
grand piano and you might have within
your Gene the keys required to play the
song Alzheimer's disease right but if
you live and eat in a certain way and we
don't have all the details in terms of
like how this might you know the the
exact road map for guaranteed prevention
so we talk in terms of reducing risk
right but you might live in a certain
way where those keys never get played on
the other hand if you consume largely
the you know a diet representative of
the standard American diet whereby Now
60 of your average Americans calories
are coming from Ultra processed foods
damn those keys are likely getting
played then you add in environmental
exposures you add in an overly sedentary
lifestyle you add an exposure for
example to cigarette smoke or chronic
alcohol consumption or traumatic uh you
know like or even non-traumatic head
injury
um then you're that's it I'm dead what
you're you're dramatically increasing
your risk again and context is
everything now my mother I will never
know what caused her dementia
unfortunately but you know my mom was
somebody who who adhered to what any
dietitian of the 70s and 80s would have
described as a perfect diet it was very
low in fat low in saturated fat low in
dietary cholesterol I never saw her eat
eggs red meat anything like that foods
that we know are highly nutrient dense
and instead she consumed mainly Ultra
processed foods but the kinds of foods
that you might see the red heart healthy
logo on in the supermarket in the in the
supermarket if it had the red heart
healthy logo on it chances are it would
have passed through my you know kitchen
at some point or another growing up we
consumed margarine instead of butter we
always had the you know the the bottle
of corn oil by the stove and the plastic
tub
which now research is beginning to show
us are not healthy alternatives
um despite their despite their marketing
she always you know ate refined grain
products but again that were low in
cholesterol unsaturated fat were
purportedly heart healthy and
unfortunately that's the dietary pattern
that my mom you know adhered to and I I
don't even know to be honest if it was
her diet you know she was also not she
was of a Generation
Um where where physical exercise wasn't
really appreciated the way that it is
now I mean you know for for her
adolescence like the the the the the the
gym membership wasn't a thing the way
that it is now so I don't think I don't
know if they uh there were no gyms there
were no gyms right right
yeah so not that you not that you need a
gym to exercise but um but you know it's
uh her lifestyle was was very different
and she aspired to be healthy that's the
grand irony of it all is that my mom was
somebody who you know she was born and
raised in New York City and had access
to healthful food
um she didn't come from money or
anything like that but she aspired her
whole life to be to be healthy and
despite that developed these awful
monstrosities
um these these awful health
monstrosities so what is nutritional
Psychiatry yes
so great question nutritional Psychiatry
is this burgeoning field looking at the
role of diet in mental health so we're
seeing mental health disorders uh
increase we're seeing
um even non-clinically people struggling
around the world with depression and
anxiety and so we are now there's now
starting to uh we're starting to develop
a growing body of evidence showing us
not just associations right not just not
just correlation where people who
consume more junk food tend to be at
higher risk of depression or people who
adhere more closely to vegan diets tend
to be at higher risk of depression but
we are now starting a randomized control
trials the kinds of Trials required to
prove cause and effect are starting to
show us that food is medicine with
regard to mental health so one of the um
one of the seminal studies came out of
the deacon uh Deacon University's food
and mood Center in Australia called the
smiles trial where they took people food
and mood the food and mood yeah clever
right nice yeah the smiles trial that's
what it is Neil's french fries
exactly yeah those patients were eating
lots of french fries there you go and
they had clinical depression and after
cleaning up their diets and giving them
uh you know a dietary pattern similar to
the one that I recommend you know a
Mediterranean Whole Foods dietary
pattern inclusive of animal products
um and and with a reduced focus on Ultra
processed what I call vending machine
Foods they saw that three times the pain
compared to standard of patients on the
standard of care intervention there was
a dramatic um rate of remission and just
symptom Improvement across the board so
we can actually use food as medicine now
with regard to mental health which is
amazing with that mess Let Me interrupt
you because right now I'm sure there are
some people who are getting the
impression not that you're giving it
that perhaps what you're saying is that
this is the preferred method of
treatment as opposed to the standard of
care that is now given to those who
suffer these maladies is that indeed
what you were saying or are you just
saying this is the uh best means of
preventing ever getting to that place in
the first place yeah it's both and all
and to be clear I'm not you know my
intent is not to place stigma on
pharmaceutical intervention the drugs do
work for a subset of depressed patients
but you know they tend to be more
effective the more severe the depression
but my argument and I think the the the
the growing argument now is that food
and lifestyle should be a front line
defense and if if that doesn't work for
you then you know by all means see a
psychiatrist and and you know and have
them work out something that's effective
for you did you did you hear about the
Doctor Who described because people were
living in a food desert he was seeing
all of these illnesses that he basically
was just like these are lifestyle
illnesses and he started prescribing
like vegetables and things like that but
he was basically saying exactly what
you're saying he was a medical doctor
and that's not to say that all depressed
people that the etiology of their
depression the is is rooted in their in
their choices that's not what I'm saying
but for certainly a subset of patients
with depression there is a role for diet
and lifestyle and it could potentially
be driven by poor food choices because
we're now there's What's called the um
inflammatory cytokine model of
depression this doesn't apply to all
depressed patients but for some
inflammation in the body can drive
symptoms of depression uh sick animal
for example an animal under inflammatory
assault with an infection for example
they display what are known as sickness
behaviors you ask any zookeeper right
like what how their animals behave when
they're sick they retract from the herd
they place they display symptoms that in
a human look a lot like depression so
today unfortunately a lot of people are
exposed to inflammatory environmental
top pollutants they eat diets that
contribute to inflammation Ultra
processed highly refined diets they're
you know they experience um they have
perhaps energy toxicity because they're
just eating too much in general and so
that can create inflammation in the body
and the Brain sits directly downwind of
that inflammatory smoke if you will and
so for those patients it it doesn't take
a stretch of the imagination to to
hypothesize that maybe cleaning up their
diets and and and and and getting to a
state of nutrient repletion and
exercising a little bit more which we
know has an anti-inflammatory effect
um Can can help and so you know why not
try that first before you know getting
onto one of these drugs which have side
effects and are very difficult to come
off of right I think you owe it to
yourself and again but Max so I'm a I'm
a physics reductionist all right so so
you could chew on the bark of this magic
tree where you can isolate what is the
pain reliever in it and you get aspirin
so you just take a pill rather than bow
and to a tree and chew on its bark so if
everything you mention that is good for
the brain and you're citing a food in
which it's found why not just put it in
a pill and then everybody takes the pill
and then we can eat what the hell we
want yeah or avoid the things that you
know are bad but we don't always have to
chase the things that have been declared
good if you can reduce it to something
that would fit in a pill what's wrong
with that yeah that that's a great
question and in the field of nutrition
that's referred to as nutritionism this
idea that you know humans that we you
know with our
especially in the field of nutrition
meager tools just distill a food down to
its constituent nutrients like we look
at an orange and we think vitamin C
right but an orange is composed of
hundreds if not thousands of chemicals
right and food has what's called an
Entourage effect and when we take these
isolated nutrients and we give them as
supplement form in clinical trials they
don't always have the expected effect
food we've co-evolved with food not
these nutrients in isolation and so you
know that's I think the the appropriate
response to that is that that makes it
hubris like what you're saying is that
um when you when you eat an orange you
are getting the vitamin C ascorbic acid
which you can find in the pill but
you're also getting collagen you're also
getting every other thing that that an
orange does for you and you can't get
that in the pill so maybe the pill is
good to undergird a certain part of your
Nutritional Health but if you make that
the essential supplement supplement
supplement yeah okay yeah but but but
but but to make that the the focus
probably won't work yeah and that's one
of my biggest one of the biggest
arguments that I have to make against
veganism again I'm not uh somebody I
gotta go I got to go I gotta go to the
bathroom he's talking about vegans
everybody duck duck everybody duck watch
out yeah and so I so I you know I don't
um people people can I don't care what
people eat I think that they should be
adopt whatever diet they want with full
informed consent the full breath of
information before they make those
choices but you know they've they've
distilled an entire massive category of
foods animal Source Products right that
we've co-evolved with there's no single
vegan hunter-gatherer tribe on the
planet and meat played you know the best
scientists that I know believe that meat
played an integral role in the evolution
of the human brain but but there's this
idea that you can distill the entire
category of animal Source Foods down to
one nutrient vitamin B12 and if as long
as you supplement with that then you're
good right you can you can X out animal
products and get and cross them off from
your from your shopping list and that's
a big problem because we know that
animal Source foods have a ton of really
beneficial nutrients that we are now
just starting to identify for example it
was just recently shown in
in both primate and mouse uh models that
taurine which is a an amino acid found
only in animal products right can
actually extend lifespan it set the
internet Ablaze you know everybody's
looking for the new for the next
Fountain of Youth and taurine is this
compound that in clinical trials in
humans has been shown to reduce blood
pressure improve glucose homeostasis
like glucose regulation and might even
actually play a role in extending your
lifespan now the dose in humans for that
effect is unclear
um but you know animal Source Products
are loaded with nutrients that seem to
improve the way that our biologies
function right creatine found in in meat
carnitine
um and so this this whole idea of like
nutritionism reducing Foods down to its
constituent nutrients and trying to
identify with all of our Hubers what is
essential and what's not well that would
only leave us with vitamin B12 which is
a huge mistake in my view well all I
know is as a comedian uh touring will
kill you
foreign
are you saying the human body is
predisposed to need certain animal
products be it Dairy be it meat fish
protein in a certain format rather than
yes
um yes but omnivore is our biologically
appropriate uh way of eating
um you can you can try to get around it
with a by playing a cat and mouse game
of nutrients pretty much your teeth your
teeth make that point for you Max let's
be honest there's a reason why we have
canines okay an interesting point right
and it ain't to eat apples yeah exactly
exactly so yeah I'm a huge uh proponent
of of omnivore I think it's like you
know and it's a very balanced approach I
think but today nothing is balanced
everything has become polarized and so
there's you know there's the vegan diet
tribe and there's now the growing
carnivore diet tribe and by sitting in
the middle you get haters on both sides
which can be uh frustrating at times but
um but yeah I'm Unapologetic in my in my
in my stance we know what to eat we know
how it works
is it now about food strategy for how we
eat do we binge do we graze do we fast
do we just get a jab of those MP what
are we doing we're going about this yeah
um that's a great question I think it's
what you eat is still more important
than how you eat when you eat but these
are all variables that are starting to
be looked at
um you know Sachin Panda for example at
the Salk Institute is a circadian
biologist who's done a lot of great work
showing us how early time restricted
eating meaning curtailing your food
consumption to uh about you know three
to four hours before you go to sleep
actually can lead to improvements in
certain markers of cardio metabolic
Health such as blood pressure and blood
sugar we also let me just we should
unpack that for a second because you
said a lot there Matt basically you know
you saying that basically everybody has
a 24-hour Rhythm to their body and their
metabolism and so that if you restrict
your uh your intake to a few hours or
cut it off a few hours before you go to
bed you can see metabolic uh benefits to
doing so
in terms of like your heart and so forth
is that right yeah without even without
even changing what it is that you're
eating which I think is really
empowering for people in food deserts
people who can't easily change what it
is that they're eating you know
um and so
yeah I mean so what the research is
showing is that first of all your
average American is eating is digesting
and metabolizing calories from the
moment they wake up until the moment
just before they go to sleep right and
that seems to be out of sync with our
natural circadian yearnings to for for
one be diurnal creatures which we are so
we're meant to eat primarily during the
day and not too close to to bedtime and
studies show for example that eating
late at night actually affects your next
day hunger rhythms So for anybody trying
to lose a little bit of weight eating
late at night might be in a way causing
your efforts to backfire they've shown
that this negatively affects next day
energy metabolism it increases hunger
and decreases your metabolic rate not by
huge margins but by margins that you
know if if regularly
um occurring and sustained might uh
presumably lead to lead to weight gain
blood pressure is a hypertension is a
major problem about 50 percent so one in
two people listening to this have
hypertension which literally I'm the one
yeah you're the one in two people
there's four of us there's four of us
yeah it's a I mean this is a big problem
I mean it's not just the silent killer
but chronically sustained hypertension
literally destroys your brain I mean
this was shown in a seminal dementia
prevention trial that that I often
reference the Sprint mind trial where
they show that people who are
aggressively treated for their
hypertension saw a significant risk
reduction for the development of mild
cognitive impairment which is considered
pre-dementia so we know that you know
your your brain is fed blood and
nutrients and antioxidants
um oxygen glucose by a network of micro
vessels and you know you might not
experience a stroke but vascular
dementia is the second most common form
of dementia and even in Alzheimer's
disease there's there's early vascular
dysfunctions my father laundry max if I
think back to my younger days and
certain vaccines all right an apple a
day keeps the doctor away but Eat Your
Greens don't go to bed on a full stomach
we've kind of known these things you
know and had them absorbed whether we've
paid attention to them or not good point
yeah but unfortunately today there's
massive pressure from whether it is the
pharmaceutical industry as you mentioned
of zempic you know there there was a
there's somebody who recently on 60
Minutes claimed a highly credentialed
physician who claimed that the primary
cause of obesity is genetic which I
think is is hugely deflating for anybody
on a weight loss Journey right it it
foments the victim mindset that oh I
guess I'm overweight or obese now like
one in two people are because of my
genes right but there are some people
and I am not
um disputing what you just said by any
stretch of the imagination there are
some people who are genetically big
people like I spent a little time in
Hawaii and I met some people that were
just big people like I mean big and
Burly and like everybody was big and but
they look at me like oh I would love to
pick you up and carry you around like a
little baby because they're big people
oh
yeah I mean there there are genetic
contributions certainly but but by and
large you know whether or not somebody
is is obese I mean this is something
that is largely environmental and by the
way people people do genetically differ
in
um not just where they carry their fat
but their their personal fat thresholds
like how fat they can get and so some
people are able to get a lot fatter than
than other people right but whether or
not you're fat or lean you still might
be exposing yourself to metabolic
dysfunction right which
um and certain people will happen at a
you know at a far lower BMI we call this
normal weight metabolic obesity
um which is is quite common about 20
percent of people that are that are
normal weight seemingly healthy are
actually metabolically obese and then
and then obesity is is on the rise but
again it's it's a largely it's an
interplay between our environment and
our genes
you know the one thing we haven't done
is talk about where do you start I mean
this is a lot of information about what
what we're doing to ourselves and our
diets and you know highly processed
foods and all that but I gotta be honest
right now I'm kind of thinking all right
what do I do yeah all right well this
this Max this must be now the next step
in the strategy so if the enemy inside
I'll call it that is the ultra processed
foods that are so abundant in super
except except I'm still I'm Max have you
explicitly said why Ultra processed
foods are bad for you
yeah I can totally go into that I mean
there yeah because I don't think we've
heard that yet yeah exactly yeah so so
Ultra processed foods are foods that you
couldn't conceivably make in your own
kitchen
um they typically lie in the aisles of
our Supermarket
um aisles now making up 73 of the of the
standard American food supply the reason
why they're they're so pernicious is
well there's a few reasons one is that
they tend to be hyper palatable so we
tend to they tend to push our brain to a
bliss Point Beyond which self-control is
nearly impossible and you know if I were
a food manufacturer I would want my
foods to be hyper palatable right it's
just another way of saying super super
bussing you know like super awesome
crack on that yeah the other the other
aspect of them is that they're highly
calorie dense and minimally satiating so
this is for a few reasons one they tend
to be low in fiber two they tend to be
depleted of protein protein is the most
satiating macronutrient and your typical
junk food
um is low in protein it's high in carbs
and fat right and the third factor that
that makes an ultra processed food
minimally satiating is that they tend to
be dehydrated so they provide no
hydration benefit which is atypical when
looking at Whole Foods and the reason
for this is that moisture in a food
impedes its shelf stability so food
manufacturers they deplete their foods
of water protein and fiber making them
minimally satiating they're highly
refined they're highly calorie dense and
the other thing about Ultra processed
foods well so so okay so I get all that
I get all that what does it have to do
with the brain
well the brain is just like it sends off
like the equivalent of the fourth of of
July fireworks when we consume them and
so we tend to over consume them there
was really elegant research and seminal
research published uh funded by the NIH
led by Kevin Hall who's a highly
credentialed obesity researcher who
found that by the time we've eaten these
foods to satiety we've already over
consumed them this is not the case with
minimally processed foods so minimally
processed foods the kinds of foods that
you would cook conceivably in your own
kitchen right single ingredient foods
that you even you know that you cook
yourself and make delicious
um when consumed to the same degree of
satiety meaning fullness meaning the
point that you're ready to get up from
the table you're happy you're good
you're you come in actually effortlessly
at a at a calorie deficit whereas these
Ultra processed foods we over consume
them so they turn you into Pirates of
the Caribbean you you can eat all you
want drink all you want but there's you
never get satisfied there you go so we
get fat they're also nutrient
what's it have to do with my brain
health
so well I mean being they're smart fat
people right yeah so so well there's a
there's a direct relationship an inverse
relationship between the size of our
wastes and our total cerebral volume so
you know being fat being being
overweight and obese drives inflammation
as I mentioned inflammation the brain
sits directly downwind of that fire
which is like essentially like a forest
fire in the body so that damages the
brain being overweight also puts you at
higher risk of type 2 diabetes which
increases your risk of Alzheimer's
disease between two and four fold
um it you know having chronically
elevated blood sugar literally damages
the blood vessels that supply blood
nutrients oxygen to your to your brain
yeah so I mean there's there if these
foods are uniquely obesogenic then right
there that in and of itself is means
that it is a threat to the brain a
pieceogenic good word yes another new
word for us um food labeling
nutrients this this this this this the
most things that you're going to buy in
a supermarket have to have some kind of
nutrient labeling are we getting
everything we need to know on there and
how do we know
what part of the product is what we
think we're going to get so for instance
if it's an orange we get everything
that's in the orange because it's nice
it's fresh but if it's this synthesized
process Ultra processed form how much of
it is left how can we work that out yeah
well I like to remind people that real
foods don't have extensive ingredients
lists they are the foods they are the
ingredients and so I think people do
need to one of the best things that
people could do uh second after reducing
their their intake of these types of
foods is to know how to read food
nutrition labels and so now you can
identify easily the added sugar content
which is essentially just empty calories
and when I grew up that wasn't that
wasn't clearly seen on the label yeah
hidden they would have four different
kinds of sugar
and then you'd see like sucrose the
regular sugar listed last and you'd
think that was all the sugar but
sugar was masquerading as four other
ingredients so I was a big Triumph I
remember when nutrition labels decided
to localize all the sugar content in one
column
yeah that was that was hugely helpful
um I think people just generally should
read uh ingredients lists
um and and become familiar with with
that and all you know many of the more
common names by which sugar goes under
um I also think that it's important to
uh you know opt for foods that are
higher in protein I mean today it's rare
to find people in the western world who
are deficient in protein but just
because we're not walking around
deficient doesn't mean that we're
consuming optimal amounts protein again
is a very powerful
um anti-obesogen if you will because
it's so satiating and so by prioritizing
protein you're not only supporting your
musculature which is incredibly
important like our skeletal muscle is
now being thought of as as a new Vital
sign if you will we're starting to see
that Frailty really plays a huge role in
our predisposition to developing
age-related chronic disease and so
protein is a really great
um magic almost uh macronutrient to to
prioritize in your diet there's this
idea that we're eating that you can eat
too much protein this is actually pretty
difficult to do because it is
self-limiting it is so important it is
so difficult to over consume
um and so that's one of the I think more
practical you don't you don't even just
to put teeth in that you don't have the
urge to binge on it right because you're
not going to sit there with a platter of
protein of any kind and go through an
entire bag of it and then open another
bag like we do with with uh with
carbohydrate Foods right yeah
carbohydrate and fat Latin Foods yeah
it's it's highly satiating it also tends
to come with it important
um micronutrients so these are the
nutrients that are arming your body with
the compounds required to fight off
aging right fight off DNA damage which
we all accrue over the course of Our
Lives to give your cells the cofactors
required to generate energy right so a
lot of people this is one of the most in
Wellness one of the most common search
um things is like how can I gain more
energy people are walking around feeling
zonked fatigued all the time like
zombies well it's because we're not
we're all nutrient deficient 90 of us
are walking around deficient in at least
one essential nutrient and our bodies
require cofactors to generate ATP energy
in our cells and so
and that is why I just use meth
works every time telling you man I could
I could walk to Kansas City from here if
I wanted to
so max is it a myth that the only way we
can supplier
enough quantity of affordable Foods is
through the ultra processed route or is
that a fact
it's a good point they're all the the
food processing industry there is a
there is a benefit to it of course it's
made food abundant widely available safe
and cheaper than ever if you look at the
percentage of the average incomes
expenditures on food it is a fraction of
what it was when I was growing up so
it's it's a lower hit to your total
budget than it is as low as it's ever
been there are people out there right
now at this moment nearly feeling the
pinch on the uh food prices yeah making
a relative statement yes sir that's
right right yeah yeah I mean but there
are but there are trade-offs right like
I mean these these Foods might make it
easy to and and we and we also need to
separate you know the notion of calories
from nutrition like yeah they provide
cheap calories yeah are those calories
coming from are those calories
nutritious are they providing adequate
nutrition for us about was 50 percent
are either diabetic or pre-diabetic so
yeah I mean we're providing cheap
calories to our population but at what
cost right if it's leaving us saddled
with with chronic illness and it's also
playing a role in soaring healthcare
costs so yeah again it is a it is a
double-edged sword um and so what is
biochemical liposuction
biochemical liposuction is a term that I
heard a migraine researcher give to the
ketogenic diet
which is uh which I thought was very a
very compelling way to think about
ketosis
but I will add that it's not just
ketosis that creates this phenomena of
biochemical liposuction anytime you are
in a a calorie deficit you are
essentially
um you are essentially
sucking fat out of your own adipocytes
and using them for fuel so it is you
know as long as you are
um you know burning more energy on a
daily basis than you are consuming you
are in a in a type of biochemical
liposuction and what you're saying is
the the energy is being drawn from your
fat rather than from from uh
carbohydrates flowing through your
system because you go into a
carbohydrate deficit and now oh my gosh
I gotta get energy from somewhere your
body gets it from your stored fat
exactly your store fat yeah I'd like
that it's a very very Graphics do you
remember our survival expert Dr
timogintan yes who they dropped him in
the middle of Alaska a Labrador and said
you know fend for yourself
and his ketosis state
are we looking here Max at keeping all
the 27 21st century medical benefits and
lifestyles of to a certain extent but go
back to a more ancestral way of
consuming foodstuffs
yeah that that's my view and some of the
more Orthodox in the Medical Nutrition
space might think that even that is you
know suggests quackery but I think that
you know we're very limited with our
with our tools in the field of nutrition
and nutrition is a very polarized field
and I think we need to and and nutrition
data is incredibly weak I mean our
dietary guidelines are based on
population level level evidence and you
know we have very few long-term
randomized controlled trials with you
know testing one dietary pattern over
another and yet if you spend any time on
nutrition Twitter or nutrition Instagram
for that matter you'd think that you
know that these different each of these
each of the many different dietary
tribes do have their answers right and
we're just not privy to them and so I
think you do this this was my sense when
I I spent time binging on every single
nutrition documentary on Netflix only to
find every single a dozen or so only to
find that there's very little
consistency from one to the next each
one had their own sort of dietary
preference and it left me wondering
whether the person who made the video it
worked for them and they're assuming
it's going to work for everybody else
but maybe not because of genetics
because of epigenetics because of
whatever else now you're making a
documentary right is it in this space
and am I am I going to line it up with
the others and what am I going to say
after I've seen 12 others and then come
to yours yeah so I'm working on a
documentary it's called Little empty
boxes people can check it out at
littleemptyboxes.com it's not out yet to
see but we have a trailer up we'll look
for it yeah um and it but it's not uh I
mean there there is science and research
in it but it's not going to be one of
these pedantic uh you know highly
prescriptive nutrition docs like like
what you see on Netflix because the
reality is that you know many diets
dietary patterns work there's no such
thing as a one size fits-all diet this
was my sense when I came in this it just
worked for all these different people
and so I said okay fine I'll you know
pick what works for me not not turn one
person's documentary into a cult you
know where because that's what it kind
of felt like they were saying if you're
not with me you're against me and join a
join us you know we are the so is that
is that nail then going forward the next
generation will want to get ahead of
what what is the food stuff nutrients so
they're gonna go and get the genomes
analyst they're going to find out what
their predisposed
to metabolize better what is better for
them is this do you think Max the way
that we're going to address this get
ahead of our own bespoke nutrition I
love that yeah that's gonna be true no
matter what Max says there's going to be
yeah you know that's true max that's got
to be the solution to this personalized
nutrition yeah but it's I think it's
it's in the distance I don't think that
it's that this is something that's
around the corner I mean there are
certainly socioeconomic you know you're
going to take out the people who can't
afford to go and buy Super Hyper fresh
local and or like all their dollar will
buy them is ultra processed I know one
thing that we can do when you talk about
how
um returning to uh our ancestral way of
eating yeah so what we do is we take all
the junk food in the supermarket right
and we make it so that you have to hunt
it because the reason why we were skinny
back in the days because we had to chase
our food and that's why you had to
expend a great deal of energy G in order
to eat so I'm not chasing down my potato
chips
you gotta hunt those potatoes yes man so
you're going to put them in a so what
we're going to do is electric carts
right right full of food that we have to
chase around the yard
there they go there goes the potatoes
and they just gotta start running to get
your chips potato chips
we start forming teams to work together
oh dear
we are just giving someone an idea for a
film it's time to end the show right now
so max it's been a delight to have you
on it's great to know that folks like
you were running around trying to make
make this world a healthier place
because without those forces operating
uh
you know I I don't I don't know why
we're even alive at all you know we're
not for the reminders of what we should
or shouldn't be doing with our body and
our minds so thank you for being a force
of good in this world thank you no it
means a lot coming for me all right yeah
and so Chuck good to have you Gary
please all right we've just concluded
another Star Talk special edition this
one on your food and your brain and your
brain on food Neil deGrasse Tyson here
as always
believe
[Music]
it